i think rishi sunak has just resigned
i'm just getting this through
on my phone a tweet here from rishi
sonic saying the chances saying the
public rightly expect government to be
conducted properly competently and
seriously i recognize this may be my
last ministerial job but i believe these
standards are worth fighting for this is
why i am resigning
so the chancellor of the exchequer rishi
sinnok has now resigned boris johnson is
now lose lost to
very very integral cabinet ministers
questions now about whether this is the
moment that the cabinet decide enough is
enough this has been
up for discussion uh for a number of
weeks with colleagues increasingly
calling on cabinet ministers uh to
resign to stand up to boris johnson uh
rishi sanak there is his letter let me
just see if i can pull it up i saw it's
on my phone and it's in tiny font let me
see if i can get that letter for you
uh i've got it here
let me read some of it to you you can
see it on your screen rishi sonak saying
it's with deep sadness i'm writing to
you to resign from the government it's
been an enormous privilege to serve our
country as chancellor of the exchequer
and i will always be proud of how during
the pandemic we protected people's jobs
he says to leave ministerial office is a
serious matter for me for me to step
down as chancellor while the world is
suffering the economic consequences of
the pandemic is not a decision i have
taken lightly he says however the public
rightly expect government to be
conducted properly competently and
seriously i recognize this might be my
last ministerial job i believe these
standards are worth fighting for that is
why i am resigning rishi sunak the now
former chancellor goes on i have been
loyal to you i backed you to become
leader of our party i respected the
powerful mandate given to you by the
british people
he goes on to say i've always tried to
compromise in order to deliver the
things you want to
achieve
but he then says i firmly believe the
public are ready to hear that truth
about making difficult decisions people
know if something's not good too good to
be true it's not true they need to know
that whilst there's a path to a better
future it's not an easy one
he says i am sad to believe in
government but i have reluctantly come
to the conclusion that we cannot
continue like this
so it started with oliver dowden
the chair of the party a close ally of
rishi sanak he resigned after those two
by
election defeats last week then there
was a question about whether or not
other cabinet ministers would resign and
we took sound ins no one seemed ready to
jump but it seems now that this chris
pincher scandal the debacle around that
the fact that the prime minister is now
apologizing and saying he's made a
mistake has led some cabinet ministers
to believe that it's time for change
that they can't in good conscience can
carry on in boris johnson's government
and that is absolutely a double blow to
boris johnson he's lost his chancellor
and he's lost his health secretary and
he has lost his party chair now there
are questions about what more cabinet
ministers will resign uh and whether the
prime minister could be forced out uh by
a cabinet no longer willing uh to
support him could this now be the
beginning of the end well is that for
boris johnson this is very very grave
for him indeed well it clearly is very
grave for him and the question is can he
survive the resignation
of his health secretary but more
particularly the res
uh resignation of his chancellor during
a cost of living uh crisis
um can he survive that that is the
the big question and many people will
say that you know these his days are
numbered now
well mark i think
the big discussion within conservative
um within the conservative party with
mps was there was an attempt to force
him out by that confidence vote and he
won the vote and no one in cabinet
resigned and he continued on
and then it became a question with some
of those rebels that wanted him to leave
to to resign
that there was an acknowledgement that
they had done what they had tried could
do on the back benches to try and unseat
boris johnson but what they then needed
was some people in cabinet to step up
and say enough is enough and resign from
cabinet and destabilize
the prime minister and that is what we
are now seeing happening in real time to
lose your chancellor and your health
secretary two of the most important jobs
i mean the chancellor of the exchequer
is the second most important job in
government boris johnson is looking
extremely vulnerable now and the big
question as sam was saying is will more
cabinet ministers follow will this be an
exodus